today we're going to talk
excuse me um
today we're going to talk about how to
get rid of phlegm that is stuck in your
lungs now far too often people reach for
over-the-counter medications and they
wonder why those treatments don't work
and sometimes even have side effects now
there's two categories that these
medications fit into you have
medications that suppress this mucus and
then you have medications that pull
mucus out that's called an expectorant
and of course anytime you suppress a
mucus or a cough you may end up having
that infection a lot longer and then you
may also weaken your immune system plus
you might have some slight minor
complications or side effects like
vomiting nausea diarrhea constipation
and kidney stones now other than that
totally fine and I'm describing the one
medication that is an FDA approved
expectorant all the other ones are
things that suppress mucus so of course
I think the best thing to do is to look
for a natural remedy which I'm going to
talk about right now but I do want to
mention it's important to exercise your
lungs if you have this mucus that's
trapped down into the lower part of your
lungs in other words you might want to
try alternating breathing to your chest
deep breaths through the nose and also
then stomach breathing
where you're pumping the diaphragm up
and down so you can mobilize some of
this mucus another important thing to
eat a lot of if you can do this is
radishes radishes tend to pull mucus
from the deeper tissues in your body
also as a side note if you have a dry
cough there's no mucus but you have this
dry cough
the usual remedy for that that usually
works like almost 100 of the time is
calcium any type of calcium you just
take it and it will tend to help get rid
of that dry cough great for kids as well
as adults in fact one of the medications
out there for blood pressure called a
calcium channel blocker works by
blocking calcium and the side effect
from that is coughing okay so in this
combination remedy it just involves
three simple ingredients in water okay
onion okay honey
and lemon let's start off with onions
onions are basically a natural
thinner of mucus they're a natural a
very effective mucous expectorant they
will help suppress a cough they
especially if it's viral in nature
they're high in Sulfur which helps break
up the mucus just like a radishes and
yes you can eat onions but you also can
juice onions if you don't have a juicer
what you do is you get a grater and you
grate the onions in a little bowl you
put that then in a strainer with some
maybe paper towel and you push the juice
out of it and all you really need is one
tablespoon of this onion juice and
that's basically 14.7 milliliters for
those people in Europe onions are also
one of the highest sources of quercetin
okay now quercetin is a natural
antihistamine and it has no side effects
so it's really good for allergies and
mucous production and inflammation and
it calms down an overactive immune
system so we're going to combine this
onion juice with the next thing on the
list which is honey now if you can get
the Manuka honey that's a little bit
better but any of the raw Honeys will
work honey has been a known great remedy
to suppress coughing to help as a
natural expectorant to help with mucus
as an antimicrobial anti-inflammatory I
mean think about what these bees do they
go around to all of these flowering
trees and plants and they pull out the
nectar and with that comes a lot of
different pollen so we have all these
factors that can help your own immune
system it's even considered like a
natural antibiotic of your respiratory
system I mean they use the Manuka Honey
on open wounds to help heal like bed
sores and Manuka honey if you can get it
has this additional X Factor it's called
MGO and this is a chemical that is a
very powerful antimicrobial but like I
said before you can use any raw honey it
will work honey also has naturally
hydrogen peroxide which is good to kill
pathogens but for upper respiratory
infections like the sinus and lower
respiratory infections it's an effective
remedy and we're going to use one
tablespoon that is 14.7 milliliters so
we take these first two ingredients we
mix it with the third ingredient which
is lemon juice right so with the lemon
juice you want to use two tablespoons
which is 29.4 milliliters and the citric
acid in the lemon juice will actually
break up mucus the vitamin C will help
the immune system and lemon is like this
sour somewhat bitter substance which is
great to kind of thin the mucus and also
cause the mucus to kind of come up so
you can get it out of the body now you
want to add these three ingredients to a
cup of water and you want to drink this
three times a day now if you want to add
a couple additional things I would add a
tablespoon of apple cider vinegar to
this and you can even add some ginger
but this is actually a no-brainer are
very simple virtually no side effect
type remedy for getting rid of mucus now
there are other causes of mucus that
need different solutions like if you
have Gerd where you're having acid
reflux coming up through this your valve
on the top of the stomach if you haven't
seen my video on that which actually got
over I think 5 million views I put that
up right here check it out